[Music]
let's go to david in charlotte what's up
david
hey dr john how are you i'm partying man
what about you
i'm doing good hey listen i need some
help uh with my marriage
you have come to the right guy what's up
yeah all right so here's the deal
i've been married for about 13 years
my wife and i have two beautiful
daughters ages 13 and 8
and in
in january my wife had surprised me by
moving out of the house
whoa why
well that's that's the thing she just
you know
um
the the disagreement um it stemmed from
our finances um and
i think she has a little bit of a
spending issue and
when she moved out
in january she had she was in debt
approximately thirty thousand dollars in
credit card debt
and
we can never get this this spending
issue that she has under control and
it just it just it kept snowballing and
it kept getting worse and
you know then it led the communication
issues misunderst understandings and a
lot of hurt feelings between the two of
us and eventually we kind of just you
know we just stopped talking we stopped
communicating and
next thing i know she sent me a text in
in january saying
you know i'm i'm ending this marriage
i'm moving out of the house and um
and and that was that so
uh fast forward so just
just before she
she moved out maybe like a week or two
before she moved out
my my older daughter
had found an inappropriate conversation
in her phone
basically she was sexting with another
man another married man
so
um you know
the next morning i believe it was the
next morning my my daughter had told me
when i gave her ride to school my
daughter told me what she found
and you know of course i was i was
really hurt
and
um
eventually i went in i went to my wife's
phone and i found it a couple days later
she had she left her phone on the
counter
and i was able to get in my wife's phone
and i found it
and
i was able to take some pictures and
some videos to see what was going on so
we i confirmed what my daughter had
found in her phone
are you still there yeah i'm here yeah
all right
so
after that
so she moved out in january
and
ever since she moved out
she's been been very very distant
and
she she tried to take she tried to take
me to court uh to try to take custody of
the kids and so we went to court
and
she ended up losing in court so i have
the cust i have custody of the kids here
at the house so you you call your first
your first question to me is you want to
save your
help with your marriage
is your marriage over
is she
i believe so uh yeah i mean you know and
it sounds like she moved out and then
she tried to take you to court
are you all still legally married or she
filed for divorce
well i i don't think she can sh
we can we can legally separate until
then you know next january
wow and and then after
i think because we have to be living
apart
for a year and then and then i think
everything finalizes
i've never heard that in my life
did y'all get attorneys
like a divorce attorney
yes yep okay and they said you just got
to sit on this for a year
right right and that's exactly it
because you know i wasn't physically
abusing her i wasn't emotionally abusing
her i wasn't yelling at her
and
you know basically the last year of our
relationship she wasn't around in the
evenings
to help out with
with the girls you know she started
working out and developed this insane
you know workout habit that she's been
at the gym okay hold on hold on
okay
all right all right all right
hopefully somebody's told you this and
if they haven't shame on them okay what
you were describing to me is very very
clear
your wife did not like the life she
had found herself in
and
it's super common
to have kids in the age ranges you're in
and somebody look in the mirror and say
this can't be all there is for me
then they go lose a ton of weight and
they go work out like crazy and then
they start cheating
and then they
fantasize about a new existence
and they think it's just gonna be simple
i'm just gonna leave and then i'll get
all my kids when i want but not when i
don't want and then i'm gonna have this
great body and this new
sexual partner and then life's gonna go
on great and my bank account's gonna be
exactly how it was all that
and so somebody
sounds like she's been cheating on you
for a while man
and it sounds like she's been out of
this marriage for a while
this isn't a question about
i i
i can't tell if you are having a trouble
facing reality or if you have
she has told you no i think i'm coming
back or you have a fantasy about her
coming back like
where are you because this doesn't help
with your marriage this is
this is you coming to terms with your
wife has left you
and what is life going to look like
now correct right right you know and i
think you hit it on the head and i think
it's all the above you know um
i love her very much and
you know um
it's hard to see her go and okay so
listen listen i'm having a heart she's
been gone for a year
been gone for a year
and now listen and here's what's really
crappy about about this
she's probably been gone emotionally for
two years
if not right
and so when she finally left
that was the end for her and that was
just the beginning for you
correct and so there is it feels like a
gap between the two of you there's a
clear gap she your wife left you okay
but there's a gap that feels bigger than
the grand canyon because you're like oh
oh this is serious let's talk about this
and in her head no i just put a period
at the end of that sentence it's over
correct right and then there's all the
legal rigamaru which the lawyers get
paid the longer it goes on
and i have utmost i'm one of the few
people in the world i defend lawyers to
the end of the earth because i think
that they play an important role i also
think that they get paid to keep things
going
yeah and so if you haven't already i
would find an attorney that says i need
this to be over as soon as possible and
i'm not interested in waiting a calendar
year
you are prolonging
your own agony and misery and you are
choosing to not grieve
you see what i'm saying
right exactly
and here let me tell you this is gonna
be hard we're about to say i'm just
telling you the truth
you're dragging your daughters through
this
and you still call her my wife and you
still call her mom and you still call
her yeah but your mother
dude your wife walked out on y'all
you're one of those guys now
and the question is what kind of life
are you going to build for you and for
your daughters out of the ashes of what
just happened
right and that starts with you facing
reality
is that fair and you hear me say this as
someone who loves you not someone who's
like talking crap at you right you hear
what i'm saying i'm not trying to be a
jerk right i'm just trying to say hey
man
right
um this is me having a conversation with
somebody in the hospital when i have to
be the one that says hey
um
there is no brain activity
your partner is dead
is it it's time to let go like no no we
can that's me telling you this sounds
like this thing's over
okay am i out to lunch am i wrong
right no you're you're right on the
money let me ask you this this is
another one of my questions so
you know if
if we were to back up you know we had
stopped communicating it was you know
because of the spending so my question
to you is
you know if she's in that much credit
card debt and she just doesn't stop
spending
do i should i have let her
continue to spend in order for her to be
happy to try and hopefully you know save
the marriage if i knew this was going to
be the case or should i have put my foot
down sooner and say hey enough is enough
and if at that point the way to stop
spending the way you're asking that
question tells me that there was some
major dysfunction in your marriage
because you're not her dad
and i put my foot down with my children
i don't put my foot down with my wife
because my wife and i work our butts off
months in advance to be on the same page
about just about everything and when we
get off the same page
we circle back and say not hey this
particular thing like so i'm the guy in
my house i'll just spend money like i'm
an idiot right i'm a what do you call a
free spirit that's what my friend rachel
calls
i gotta see a thing i work real hard and
i just want to go get it
when i do that my wife doesn't come at
me and say i can't believe you spent
money that's not how she asks me
she said hey you and i've got goals that
we all agreed on
and
something must be going on in your life
for you to violate these goals what's
going on man
because you don't seem like you're okay
right that's different then you can't do
this
because she's not my mom
she's my
she is part of me the way you refer to
your wife as she's running up her money
you've got a you've got a a pronoun
issue in your marriage that's y'all's
money
because y'all are all right you see what
i'm saying so something up got separated
it might have been the way you always
had this thing
or maybe your wife was tired of you
acting like her father or maybe she
kept acting like a child and you were
left to try to clean up the i don't know
what the challenge was but we got to a
place where so to answer your question
directly if i had that exact same
situation in our house
the way i would have it the conversation
i would have is
hey to my wife
you and i agreed we want to get out of
debt you and i agreed we don't want to
have a house payment as crazy as that is
you and i agreed we're going to drive
crummy cars until we pay off our house
and get our kids fully funded for
college so they're going to have less
worries than we did
we've agreed on these things
and your actions are not in alignment
with what we agreed a
but
are we okay but here
here's the thing she wouldn't she thinks
life is too short to save at all so she
won't even
we're always so so negative in the
account so a she's very immature very
very immature
and b
you
around here we call it financial
infidelity she was cheating on you with
money it's a power play it's financial
abuse okay and i would treat the
infidelity as such
okay life's
trust me life's too long to not save
it's way too long you're not safe right
we have to it's just immaturity
but here's the thing it is a symptom of
the immaturity
it's not the thing to be solved what's
to be solved is a decision to act like
an adult
and yes at some point if you were
married to somebody and they are
draining your account and they were
putting your family at risk and they are
cheating on you with their money
you have to make a decision for the
safety of your children the safety of
you the safety of like this becomes
abuse it becomes infidelity and i've
said this before on the show i think
infidelity is a much bigger conversation
than who puts what body part where and
with who
infidelity is are we on the same page we
agreed to be this
and you opted out
right and now we're gonna have a harder
conversation cheating is a much bigger
picture than making out with somebody
and so
uh all i have to say is
this
money is a symptom of a much bigger
issue
bottom line your wife has laughed
and i i'm literally i can hear it on you
you need to spend some time
there not with will my marriage
she's gone she's been gone for a year
and now it's about
grieving this thing sitting in this
thing and then what happens next
hang on the line jenna's gonna send you
a copy of my new book i want you to read
it straight through okay i want you to
read it straight through because the
back half of that book is what do we do
now
and i want you to go find a counselor
or a couple of buddies that aren't going
to be like yeah bro but are going to
listen to you as you say the words my
wife has left me and my marriage is over
and i don't know what to do next
okay and i want you to rally your
daughters up and say hey i'm coming to
terms with mom has left i want you to
call an attorney and say i need this
faster than a year and maybe that's the
law in north carolina i don't know good
god it's crazy i can't imagine that is
um
but i'm sure somebody can write me and
let me know what the deal is but
anyway
sorry man
i'm sorry
the only only the light here i can offer
you is there's healing on the back end
of this okay there's healing on the
other side but you're gonna have to walk
through it